although we're in the middle of this
alleged ceasefire from a military
perspective you look back in history
ceasefires do crop up every now and
again but they're incredibly complicated
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of soldiers spread over
hundreds of kilometers of front line
coordinating and making sure everybody
agrees the terms negotiating it is
incredibly incredibly difficult to do
um and this besides you know back in
December 14th the Kremlin said that
there was going to be no ceasefire for
Christmas so the very fact that Putin
announces this with 24 hours to go it
has no credibility in reality it's
almost certainly been played for a
domestic audience it's worth pointing
out of course that Putin exactly as Alex
said Putin's military desperately need a
break from the fighting they're on the
back foot they're being hit they need to
reconsolidate Etc so it's no doubt that
it's been dismissed and there's a lot of
hypocrisy I think here um if you look
back the ukrainians that were the
civilians were being targeted by the
Russians over Christmas and New Year the
only people that the ukrainians can
fight is the Russian military and now
they're asking for C Inspire to respect
a different religious Festival it's a
gross hypocrisy and it's no doubt that
that's why the reason zelenski is not
going to honor it okay all right so
that's no surprises there um Ukraine
also
um receiving some armed vehicles from
the U.S Germany and France how
significant is that yeah it's like it's
package of Aid I think we've got a
picture of the French AMX
um uh here
um it's not tanks it's armored vehicles
for transporting soldiers around the
French again the AMX Americans giving
the Bradley their maneuver platforms
they allow the Ukrainian soldiers to
move very effective around the
battlefield add an element to surprise
um Solinski has asked for tanks in the
past that's a bit problematic because
they're incredibly complicated Machinery
lots of different spares different sizes
of ammo that he doesn't have and besides
lensky famously described that the
biggest donor of Tanks to Ukraine is is
Russia itself because it's been
abandoning them and of course if it's
got tanks given to it that it's used to
operate and it has the spares it's much
more useful but these armored vehicles
they will undoubtedly help protect you
Ukrainian lives they'll provide more
intelligence on the battlefield but
they're not empty shells they are full
of complicated equipment therefore
they're going to take some training to
get them to be able to be used properly
and that will take time all right and
just a lightning tour around Ukraine if
you would to tell us where the flash
points yeah the really quick updates up
in the north p66 just north of spit over
that's where the Russians are
resupplying their effort the ukrainians
using Wester weapons to Target that and
if we look at back moot fighting
continuing ground or halt the Wagner
mercenary group have been throwing
soldiers at that but it's Urban Warfare
every building is a fortress they've
actually grown to a whole Wagner group
now are complaining blame game starting
saying that Russia hasn't provided
enough equipment and and ammunition
harsh reality is and it's incredibly
difficult so despite the fact it's
winter despite the fact that um there's
meant to be a ceasefire this war grinds
on